defense secretary Ben Wallace is with us
from Brussels Mr Wallace good morning
thought on the inflation figure first of
all please good morning
uh well good morning Kay and uh welcome
back from uh your trip look I I think uh
look it's the right it's the right
direction it's positive uh I think it
shows that the government's efforts
alongside others to try and make sure
that we deal with inflation because
inflation is really the number one enemy
to the economy is in the right direction
but you know uh we've got a long way to
go uh we'll have to keep working on it
and uh you know I think as as your
commentator said you know the bank of
England's Target is two percent and
we're at 10 and no one likes to be
living in a in a place of high inflation
but I I really welcome the direction of
travel and we must keep working at it
okay let's talk about money should we uh
an uphill battle with the treasury
um how much money do you need just to
stand still okay I've I've been in this
uh game long enough I think uh been a
minister for I don't know how many years
but it's always uphill battle with the
treasury no matter what department
you're in it's it's the right thing that
a secretary of state will argue for an
increase to meet their priorities uh and
of course between now and the budget
I've got lots of time and lots of
meetings with the chancellor to make
sure that we uh uh try and come to a
deal on it and I think uh you know I
haven't hidden the fact that we suffer
from inflation pressures as does
departments with big Capital spending
that's that's spending on hardware and
infrastructure because of course that's
where inflation goes to but um you know
we'll see I mean I'm not going to
conduct the negotiations in public but
uh obviously we're going to try and make
our way through this so that between now
and the next spending review which is in
two years time uh we can insulate
defense from many of those pressures so
you're looking according to the times
between 8 and 11 billion and I've seen
lots of reports of how much I'm looking
for uh I as I said okay I'm not going to
conduct negotiations of Treasury in
public I think we've got plenty of time
I'm very much conscious of of the
overall government ambition which is to
drive down inflation as I've just said
earlier in the program that is key that
of course means it's going to pinch all
of us in all our departments because you
know ultimately the answer cannot
therefore be to flood everything with
extra spending or more borrowing but I
also know that we have a growing threat
on the world and stage and that's why
you know I'll obviously negotiate with
the treasury about where we can get to
to cover the next two years before we
get to the next comprehensive spending
review so is are you going to roll over
that or is it an issue of resignation if
you don't get what you want no no let's
just go to the budget okay I think first
and foremost most important thing is uh
that I present a good case uh to the
chancellor good case the Prime Minister
and of course the Prime Minister
Chancellor together will discuss how we
can get uh overall within the spending
envelope that's the spending review we
just indicate to the markets that we're
not going to sort of just break our own
fiscal disciplines and then we'll see uh
you know what I get at the end but this
is not about uh resigning or anything
else it's about delivering defense to
meet the threat that's my duty to to the
public no matter what political party I
am or anyone else my successes will be
the same is to to be able to fund
defense to protect us from you know the
likes of Russia and other countries
around the world so suggestions um in
the papers that you'd reside if you
didn't get where you wanted a Tosh
I don't know where that comes
from but you know okay at this moment I
have to tell you there's an awful lot of
speculation in the newspapers most of it
seems to be untrue
okay uh when are we sending fighter jets
to Ukraine
uh well at the moment I've been quite
clear with that is first and foremost
what we're focusing on is delivering for
Ukraine the effects that they need which
is either the ability to strike in the
Deep that's a longer range and that's
why things like the m270 or the high
Mars are in and indeed the use of uavs
that can drop ammunitions is another way
of delivering that effect the other one
is the effect of anti-air that is
required which a fighter can deliver but
also surface-to-air missiles which is
why the International Community is
donated now thousands of anti-air
missiles I think the first point is the
effect in the long term what we've got
to do is help Ukraine's resilience uh
potentially post conflict to make sure
that they can defend themselves and
their skies and that's why training
people to fly fighter jets is an
important step in that direction but you
know this this the key here is that
these are fighter jets these are not
handheld anti-tank weapons these are
these are aircraft that take not only
months to train on but also aircraft
that require effectively a very
substantial pit crew to support it if
you think about you know it's very diff
different gifting a sort of normal car
that you and I might drive around with
and a Formula One car you gift a Formula
One car it comes with a pit crew it
needs the crew to start it he needs the
crew to service it is a long tail that
goes with a fighter aircraft and I think
you know we can help Ukraine sooner by
delivering the effects they need on the
battlefield rather than the platform
specific uh request
Can't Give Them Enough ammunition though
can we
I think we're giving them lots of
ammunition and we continue to do so if
you look at the amount of the
International Community have donated
we're talking tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands of rounds of ammunition uh
Munitions we've just we continue to put
in 2.3 billion pounds worth of support
within this financial year another 2.3
billion next year and we are actually
putting in a huge amount K the questions
that we will be making sure we help with
is getting it delivered getting it
across the border remember we can't fly
in this equipment because of Russia's
efforts to shoot down anything that was
would be flying and we bring them in
obviously across border and we make sure
we get it to them in the front line and
you know look the ukrainians are doing a
fantastic job uh and in under very
difficult circumstances the uh later
sort of Russian effort uh around a town
a mining town
um produced uh sadly but but
nevertheless necessarily the Ukrainian
fight uh made sure that literally a
brigade of Russians was wiped out over
the last week that's nearly over a
thousand men killed because of poor
Russian equipment and poor Russian
strategy
China hacking our CCTV cameras
uh well they're not hopefully I don't
think they are hacking our sensitive
CCTV cameras uh and uh you know we take
every effort to protect areas that are
sensitive uh from anybody hacking it
whether it's China or whether it is
another nation and there are two parts
okay to protecting other structure one
is to make sure that the quality of the
equipment we buy is protected from being
hacked uh and that doesn't really matter
who makes it it's making sure that if we
buy sort of cheap knockoffs you're going
to be in a position where you're going
to be more vulnerable in whether you're
buying for your home equipment or
whether you're buying uh for a
government organization or a local
Council or a business you should always
make sure you're buying good quality as
a way to protect yourself and then the
second one is as you point out whether
or not we think they're particularly
vulnerabilities in in products sourced
from certain countries such as China and
you'll remember the Huawei debate where
the government took a decision that it
would rid its sensitive networks of
anything to do with Huawei and that's
the direction of travel we're going in
doing enough to help the people in the
earthquake zone in Southeastern turkey
and Northwestern Syria the British
public raised 65 million pounds in four
days doing the the maths it looks as
though the government has given maybe
about 11 million pounds worth of Aid so
far as they're more coming
well first of all okay there's there's
Aid in cash and there's Aid in kind
um you know I've deployed a role to
hospital which I think is going to be
set up from today I've deployed a C-130
Hercules with a critical care crew that
can move casualties around Turkey we've
provided lots of Transport a400 Aircraft
to move in both humanitarian Aid and
other Aid and I'm here in NATO today
where the Secretary General has asked me
if there's any more
um airlift I can provide to help NATO
supplies go in of humanitarian Aid and
we're going to do that so in kind I
think we've provided and we'll continue
to provide an awful lot in value
um I almost daily speak to my or or I'm
in text engagement or indeed communicate
with my Turkish can depart Minister
akkar uh only the day before yesterday I
offered him uh troops if he needed it to
help in that humanitarian effort and for
now we are in the hands of the Turkish
Authority and the United Nations in
Syria if they request more we are very
very open to looking at that okay let's
just finish briefly where we started the
treasury thinks the mod wastes money do
you
uh well I think the treasury will make
that point as I asked for more money uh
look historically the trade the Mad has
bought into equipment uh that I think
hasn't necessarily delivered but
remember 85 of our procurements are on
budget on time some of the major
projects they span 20 years and in that
time threat changes technology changes
and inflation changes and of course that
often leads to you know very difficult
conversations about either how many
units we can buy in the end or indeed
cost control but it can be better you'll
be glad to know that since I became
defense secretary and we've delivered a
balanced budget for two years and and
heading towards three that's the first I
think almost since the war that we've
managed to get those results
consistently but you know I'm fixing
projects that were commissioned as far
back as the labor government you know
the Ajax uh vehicle which is often
quoted was commissioned in March 2010 uh
and has been a troubled program and
we're now in a place where I think it's
back on track our it's passed its first
level of Trials and we're interested
next set so you know I think uh you
can't you can't hold the sins of my
forefathers against me I'm determined to
make sure we we change those practices
but that doesn't also change the fact
that threat is growing and what we've
seen since 1991 since the end of the
Cold War is a consistent effectively
raiding of the defense budget uh uh over
time and maybe a peace dividend was uh
appropriate uh straight after the Cold
War we had huge armies in Europe the
Cold War finished and it was right that
the taxpayer who had invested in defense
got a return on that the problem is that
continued and has continued to farm too
many decades as the threat has increased
and I've been very open here that the
threat has increased and just like other
parts of government when demand threat
increases we should reconsider how much
we fund it which is why Boris Johnson
and Rishi sunak when he was Chancellor
gave us 16 billion pounds extra uh back
in 2020 it was the first real turning of
the corner with real money rather than
sort of fantasy efficiency saving the
things that were supposedly the way they
used to fund that that sort of increase
and that has allowed us to start
modernizing our Armed Forces which has
been desperately needed but genuinely
start to modernize our Armed Forces okay
um hopefully Jeremy Hunt was listening
to you good to talk to you as always
safe journey back home thank you